all right I'm GNA try to do this all in
one take I'm tired and we've been
beating each other up so I don't want to
kill I don't want my de to be too tired
okay so uh couple things
um uh when the person comes in you
always fade I like that you fade there
till you get that hand light again
okay but when you do the fade it's
important that you bait him with the
other hand so I use my other hand out
here
no no different than I want him to
attack my head I with the sword workor I
I expose my head so he goes for it so
you go you want to bait with the other
hand so I kind of show it with him and
then I will come around to take energy
off of that hand so yet one there it is
and I expose it to
him absorb expose it to him but I don't
let him ever get
it
one expose it to him and then I bring it
back to my
Cent one expose it to bring it to
Myer front of me
okay all right now the mistake that
you're making is very common is you'll
feel a lot of
energy on these hands like that okay and
no
and so you'll keep that hand and you
want it to be part of your CQ hole but
the more you turn that hand the more he
moves away from the
Thro so you have in essence two young
hands coming here young hand and then a
young hand here that doesn't
work you need a Yin hand so the yin hand
comes around and I give it to him here
here go around
camera you give him the hand okay and
now you are in essence in the same way
we always do c ho so I'm on the side of
him uh and he's stuck on my shoulder
okay don't push back here every all my
destiny come to Virginia
spot no I know you this inal energy but
this hand does not keep pushing back
this hand goes up you see and then you
enter
[Music]
across again one bait give it to him go
around camera and when you give it to
him you're now in that same shoulder
lock on on his head okay again don't
just come back to accelerate
this time comes up and you come around
he won't come forward like he just
did okay one two give it to him up
in one B give it to him up
in one F give it to him up
in F give it to him
[Music]
up
for
so you're you're using the centrifugal
energy you don't use the centrifugal
energy for the Thro you cut across the
centrifugal energy okay try it
again yes can you see so he can run out
of that go run out of it he just he goes
with you runs you keep turning he just
runs out of it you're you're you're
never going to get across
his angle disturbance try it again keep
it
up right there do you see that that's
what everyone thinks we're doing and
that's
where
[Music]
um that's where your scaredy cat UK is
Will they'll take that dive okay um but
so too will count a person that's trying
to counter so let me show you where that
is okay go slower so I can talk he comes
around I give it to him okay and that
pulls that turn there puts him here on
my upper arm you guys see that and I
will not continue to rotate my shoulders
into this throw you see and that's what
you keep doing Sean and you keep doing
it too okay
so again Watch we're all thinking as
long as I keep rotating my
shoulders but I can't get ahead of this
spiraling pattern okay and me I'm not
using the x pattern okay so as it comes
around my shoulders as soon as I got
that my shoulders stop rotating they
don't they don't keep turning this hand
goes up and I
across acoss across the Closs okay we'll
do that same side one b boom as I'll
turn I'll turn to get him there now I
passed the adhesion point from the grip
up to the head and now this is doing the
Thro okay that's all you're doing it's
no different on tension nugget I'm going
to use the adhesion point of the grip to
generate the adhesion point on the neck
and that's where I
use now that part okay so you're passing
the adhesion point he comes around I
will turn as much as I need to till he
there now now I feel the adhesion on the
upper arm now if I keep rotating my
shoulders even on the entry he is just
ahead of me the whole time okay
so
instead turned to get get huge there it
is and now it's just across don't keep
rotating
your okay again yes he's making a circle
but I don't paint a circle okay one more
time turn there it is now I go straight
across okay try it again this y hand
that I did
that's so I can get this transference
right here on the upper arm okay that's
when I give it after I have
it
don't leave it back
there there see
that so I'm I go around there it is you
see so come camera go to the back if you
can get
him without putting that hammer lock on
better got it but you'll never get it by
trying to keep the hand in front of you
cuz he would just keep going around
you he wouldn't get the thing okay so
remember your whole goal is to trade the
iian contact point and once you have it
then F this then then you can take it
back okay so up pull HP then you can
take it back okay so don't F
size
this true but you can't do this
either okay you're just understanding it
boom there he's there then boom and you
do the movement do you understand that
okay try it go it's the same Coke you
hold
K okay so people go here and they don't
have contact you see and then when they
bring the hand up now they get
contact okay that's not
correct so you bring him to that upper
arm you you already have
contact and it's the upper arm that
brings him around with the adhesion okay
okay it's not your hand come around and
then your hand goes back that's that's
not it okay you bring hand to boom
that's it now you can let go doesn't
matter
okay same exact thing here he comes
around you're here okay you need to have
adhesion there got
it you can't have
Bo that's when you no that's not going
to work
okay so you're going to wrap him around
till you get there oh that's what I have
that's what I want to feel okay and
again hi can like all everything you
still get the technique do you guys
understand so
again the the incommon the wrong
assumption is that you're like oh I do
have contact no no no no
here's where he needs to be not out
there and then you move to him you have
to bring him into you boom and now this
goes up okay all right try it again okay
my my people are having this mistake
Kristen gets it a lot of the times but
everyone else is doing goofy stuff so I
imagine anyone that's going to try this
technique is going to leave this part
out okay and what they do instead is
they're not paying attention to the last
part they just come here and go like
that see what that does is it keeps him
moving on the same Circle so I can't cut
across it so I won't have the x pattern
so I can't deconstruct the base from
this relationship to a line of gravity
so I don't really have a falling
geometry I have a need for a
choreography okay
so what happens is they're like well
here's where the technique should have
happened you see should have happened
here so now they go like that no you
have to understand what you're doing on
this part and how you're doing it okay
so I have one contact point I have
another contact Point okay and I will
use the two together to move his body so
it's not that I'm getting out of the way
I see where his head is and I know where
it needs to be okay so I'm going to
connect to his Center you see
I'm moving him it's not that I'm in here
and I move him me okay I am moving but
he is moving with my movement you see
now all I have to do here is one more
turn where I leave him where I'm putting
him or I turn it a rate faster and there
it is right there then it's right
there so
move with him there it is
and he he could feel it it's pretty
tight into me okay as opposed to here
and then you're now just pushing him
ahead of you on the circle so your goal
here is to turn him boom there it is
right there and just like regular
kall when you come here and you bring
him in you can do the throw without your
hand ever going here
right he's going that way the same thing
here I come is tight and it's the same
thing you're just come out with your
spiral got it now have one turn around
so you feel it it's tight tight tight
then up then in
Finish don't get
last
SP
turn there it is
Boom turn till it's tight till it's
tight tight tight tight okay try it
again so I do my couole like this all
the time but again the ego triarte mind
will focus on the surface of things so
they see this big spiral in Geometry but
they then make the mistake that I'm
actually making a spiral I'm not making
a spiral okay so if uh I'm here give me
your other hand okay and I'm here like
this we're going to use this grid
pattern okay I am not going to try to
turn him into the throw that you guys
see so again we know I can't turn my
shoulders because he's going to stay
ahead of me
okay and uh towards that end then if
this hand goes around like you're going
this way and this hand goes that way
your shoulders just
turned so what I do is this hand goes
up I'm going to enter straight
across this
way and then that hand drops straight
down
[Music]
onto creating if you look again we use
Andrew's 30° quad turn and to get the
tissues senu to feel the
torque so I'm not going to go here it's
going to go to the other side this is
where my hand goes so
again
up enter
down this
way not up step on an
arc nor turn my
hips nor does my arm go
out my arm goes up that's where you have
that contact Bo I step
in down it
goes
J I'm here up it
goes in I go hand starts to
drop that's the
technique okay I step on a
[Music]
turn
it's going to be hard to do
resist can't I can't do
it if I throw on the turn again
resist canot make my hand go like
that my hand goes
up into the in
space my body
enters and I drop him down on the x
pattern so that is what's Happening
Here
boom round I tighten up till he's there
oh look up I enter
across drop my
hat
okay try it